[Musique]
Elisabeth Roger Lefebvre bonjour bonjour
vous êtes la directrice du CAE le
Conseil d'Architecture
urbanisme environnement des Yvelines
alors on va on va peut-être définir ce
qu'est le rôle et la mission du CIO le
rôle de l'émission du c.io et puis il y
a beaucoup d'actualité dont on va parler
auquel d'ailleurs les habitants peuvent
participer pour la plupart d'entre elles
d'abord qu'est-ce que c'est le CAE alors
je suis architecte turbaniste et laisser
a eu existent dans la plupart des
départements de France nous avons été
créés par la loi sur l'architecture de
1977 pour conseiller les particuliers
les élus toutes les personnes qui ont
besoin d'un conseil sur nos sujets du
cadre de vie l'architecture l'urbanisme
l'environnement le paysage et
aujourd'hui avec le réchauffement
climatique tout ce qui concerne
la réhabilitation du bâti
particulièrement et aussi la
désimperméabilisation des sols sujet
très très important oui parce que c'est
vrai qu'on est un mot de changement
d'abord dans la façon de construire on
va en parler de bâtir et dans la façon
aussi d'aménager les les habitations
donc vous êtes situé à ces Guyancourt
c'est Montigny Montigny voilà enfin à 50
ans quand on peut dire comme ça donc on
peut si on est un particulier on peut
oser la porte du du CU où on sera on
sera bien sûr on a pour mission de
conseiller l'ensemble des personnes qui
s'intéressent à ces sujets donc les
particuliers sont un de nos publics bien
sûr et ils peuvent nous appeler prendre
rendez-vous
on les conseille sur tout ce qui
concerne leur habitat aussi bien pour
les copropriétés que pour les
particuliers dans leur maison une
extension sur l'évasion un changement
une construction neuve voilà comment on
fait
est-ce que vous conseillez par exemple
des architectes ou pas non alors parfois
si parfois quand on sent qu'il y a une
vraie volonté d'architecture on connaît
des confrères qui s'intéressent à la
maison individuelle c'est pas si souvent
le cas donc on peut transmettre des
informations à ce sujet et on organise
bien tout une rencontre des architectes
des Yvelines au c.a.e pour justement
savoir ce qui sont vraiment intéressés
par ce sujet de la maison individuelle
ou de la construction pour le
particulier c'est vrai que le la
question de la maison individuelle elle
commence à se poser enfin c'est
notamment on va des écologistes qui
disent au fond il faudrait pas devoir
maison individuelle c'est très
énergivore mais on peut aussi on a aussi
des moyens de faire des constructions
individuelles qui sont pas voilà qui
sont pas une atteintes à l'environnement
on Ess
au moins construire en ces talons
effectivement donc moins de maisons
individuelles mais en même temps il faut
réhabiliter toutes celles qui existent
donc c'est souvent
et beaucoup de maisons individuelles
dans des lotissements qui ont été
construits au même moment donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ce sont des
propriétés horizontales et on peut
trouver des solutions pour les réalités
avec un de manière typologique un peu
toute de la même manière donc ça permet
de réduire les coûts et c'est un sujet
très très important effectivement
et c'est vrai qu'il y a régulièrement
d'ailleurs au saüe des expositions avec
des conseils qui sont donnés pour les
méditations bon enfin pour toute une
série de travaux qui peuvent être faits
et donc il y a souvent des expositions
qui sont itinérantes d'ailleurs je crois
alors en ce moment on a une exposition
itinérante proposée collectivités aux
communes qui peuvent la prendre
élus et notre exposition actuellement
s'appelle transformer le bâti justement
pour montrer des manières de faire à la
fois sur des maisons individuelles sur
des bâtiments publics des copropriétés
également des bâtiments collectifs
vous êtes alors on les voit pas parce
qu'ils ont la mais vous êtes venus et
vous avez des stagiaires vous avez des
archers vous êtes combien d'architectes
aussi on est 11 personnes mais six
architectes de paysagistes une
assistante une documentaliste parce
qu'on transmet aussi beaucoup
d'informations et elle a un rôle très
important absolument considérable
et des études que l'on a réalisées et
qui peuvent être à nouveau transmises
aux communes et puis on a aussi une
chargée de communication d'accord donc
voilà
n'hésitez pas si vous êtes voilà si vous
avez un problème de
adaptation d'achat d'un d'un logement à
venir prendre rendez-vous avec le salut
alors
on va parler maintenant de vos
actualités il y en a il y en a plusieurs
il y a d'abord votre assemblée générale
c'est le 20 juin je crois le 20 juin
après-midi un joueur pour chartin
alors bon ça c'est faut dire ça vous
concerne mais il y a une conférence qui
est qui s'annonce passionnante
puisque leur chemin architecte qui
s'appelle Philippe Madec et je crois que
le thème de cette conférence c'est enfin
il est de l'auteur d'un manifeste pour
la frugalité heureuse et créative c'est
ça alors c'est un architecte qui depuis
longtemps et c'est de réduire son
empreinte carbone quand il construit et
avec deux autres
architectes et bureaux d'études il a
inventé ce manifeste qui a été signé
maintenant par 15000 personnes en France
le CIA adhéré tout de suite à cette
démarche et on essaie de faire en sorte
que le réseau des personnes intéressées
par la frugalité augmente petit à petit
parce que construire de manière frugale
c'est utiliser les produits de la terre
intelligemment d'accord
recycler ou construire avec des
matériaux recyclables
tendance enfin des penseurs de
l'écologie d'arriver à une comme dans la
nature dans la nature rien ne se perd et
c'est un peu ça
est en train de construire une école à
Achères qui est en construction bois et
paille et on a fait déjà visiter lors de
nos éco rencontre on organise des autres
qu'on rencontre toute l'année et cette
école sera particulièrement frugale dans
ces matériaux dans sa manière de
consommer ensuite du chauffage
tout est fait de manière à ce que il n'y
est il y ait le moins de chauffage
possible et le moins de de
climatisation
de se réchauffer c'est vous disiez la
l'école c'est bois et paille c'est quoi
les matériaux
qui qui incarne la frugalité alors la
terre aujourd'hui on utilise beaucoup la
terre par exemple la terre extraite du
Grand Paris Express ce grand tunnel qui
est construit qui est qui est décaissé
et dont la terre est réemployée pour
fabriquer de la brique qui est utilisée
pour construire et il y a une fabrique
de terre enfin de briques de terre qui
est visitable quand j'ai oublié le nom
et qu'il est possible d'aller visiter
cette architecture friable quoi et une
école des Yvelines a été construite avec
des briques de cette terre extrait du
Grand Paris à Villepreux et on a fait
visiter également une un bâtiment qui se
trouve à Meulan un petit annexe d'un
hôpital qui est aussi construite avec
ses briques de terre extrait du Grand
Paris
en construction en construction
également
et est-ce que je sais pas si vous avez
la réponse à cette question mais est-ce
que dans l'opinion après tout quand vous
recevez par exemple des particuliers ou
si on leur dit ça va peut-être pas mal
de vous faire une maison au bois et en
paille est-ce qu'ils ont pas
l'impression de revenir à
la Préhistoire non parce que aujourd'hui
les habitants sont de plus en plus
intéressés par ces questions et
demandeurs parce qu'ils regardent sur
internet il se documente beaucoup et ce
sont les premiers à être intéressés
alors la fabrique de terre s'appelle
cycle terre et elle est à Sevran donc il
est possible d'aller visiter cette
usine finalement de briques de terre
alors c'est une petite usine évidemment
mais c'est ce sont des architectes qui
ont proposé au grand à la Société du
Grand Paris de fabriquer ces briques de
terre à partir de la terre extraite de
leur chantier du Grand Paris on n'est
pas dans le on est dans le présent quoi
c'est déjà voilà avoir des avoir des
constructions de ce genre de
construction frugales et
justement
c'est intéressant que des écoles des
usines aussi se mettent à cette
architecture c'est la preuve que voilà
c'est probablement vers là qu'il faut
qu'il faut aller on est un basculement
de toute manière il faut y aller donc
connaître des bonnes manières de faire
c'est aussi notre rôle en tant que ciao
de faire connaître toutes ces toutes ces
projets et toutes ces manières de faire
donc est-ce que vous-même alors vous
êtes architectes et puis vous connaissez
beaucoup d'architectes évidemment
pour les architectes que vous êtes c'est
un défi cette façon de construire de
manière nouvelle alors c'est un défi
d'autant plus que aussi donc on essaie
de travailler avec des matériaux
recyclés avec des matériaux biosourcés
donc la terre la paille le bois mais
aussi on essaie de ne plus démolir et ça
c'est un sujet primordial également
c'est à dire moins en démolira mieux ce
sera parce que la démolition entraîne
des coûts
de
déplacement de déchets dont on ne sait
pas quoi faire donc moins en démolie
mieux c'est aussi donc c'est trois
sujets là sont très importants ça veut
dire que on va pas on n'est pas dans une
on va justement détruire tous les tous
les tous les logements qui sont pas ils
seraient pas aux normes actuelles pour
en mettre pour faire des des logements
par exemple on paye en bois non on va
essayer des adapter c'est ça voilà on va
essayer des adapter de les transformer
et c'est un sujet très intéressant pour
les architectes jusqu'à présent les
architectes étaient dans la construction
pure et aujourd'hui dans les écoles
d'architecture on apprend aussi à
transformer et c'est un vrai projet
d'architecture la transformation alors
qu'auparavant c'était on se disait bon
la réhabilitation c'est pour certains
qui se mettent
le plus noble c'était la construction et
puis après bon sur le par la
construction vous pouvez faire de la
réhabilitation aujourd'hui c'est aussi
important alors que l'autre et c'est
vrai qu'on est ce que vous dites on est
un tournant
qui est passionnant et pour vous et pour
nous aussi pour les habitants qui sont
qui sont là alors ça c'est donc le 20
juin à joueurs Pontchartrain
et la conférence elle est privée ou elle
est la Conférence Est publique
il faut s'inscrire sur notre site
internet d'accord et on est accueilli au
contraire on sera très content d'avoir
un maximum de la salle est très grande
donc on peut avoir beaucoup de monde
20 juin joueur pour jardin alors il y a
un autre
événement qui est intéressant je l'ai là
c'est pas les enfants du patrimoine
alors là on a un peu plus de temps en
septembre le vendredi 15 septembre
alors en quoi ça consiste les opérations
alors les enfants du patrimoine c'est
une manifestation que les c.ae
d'Île-de-France ont créé il y a plus de
15 ans maintenant avec un partenariat
avec la DRAC la direction régionale de
l'action culturelle du ministère de la
Culture pour faire en sorte que des
visites sont organisées pour les
scolaires c'est-à-dire ce sont des
visites pour les enseignants avec leurs
classes la veille des Journées
Européennes du paysage du patrimoine la
veille des Journées européennes du
patrimoine avec des visites gratuites
donc chaque ciao sollicite c'est
partenaires et il y a un site dédié sur
lequel les classes peuvent s'inscrire
c'est des écoles qui s'inscrivent donc
actuellement on a déjà 26 visites
différentes proposées le Château de
Rambouillet par exemple propose trois
visites le musée de Marly-le-Roi en
organise également alors ça ce sont des
visites plutôt patrimoniales mais on a
aussi du patrimoine naturel proposé
comme la visite du parc du Peuple de
l'Herbe de Carrières-sous-Poissy
organisé par le
organisé par le Conseil départemental et
le CAE organise des visites qui
s'appellent habiter la ville avec ses
partenaires des Archives départementales
et le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ici avec un
circuit dans la ville nouvelle de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines comme
souvent les villes nouvelles ça a été ça
a été un chantier formidable pour les
architectes enfin il y a beaucoup de
grands architectes qui ont travaillé
notamment le bâtiment dans lequel nous
sommes
un des produits des concours
d'architecture alors je sais pas c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un bâtiment
un peu de verre et d'acier ici je sais
pas si aujourd'hui on construirait comme
ça
n'est pas frugal et rééviter un bâtiment
de ce type est extrêmement compliqué
alors peut-être qu'on ferait une
nouvelle enveloppe par exemple c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on réfléchit à
mettre des bâtiments comme des boîtes
dans la boîte dans leur proposer d'être
moins énergies et les architectes
qui ont gagné le prix preachler cette
année
je trouve
là-dedans
de proposer une nouvelle enveloppe au
bâtiment parce que c'est peut-être un
moyen justement d'avoir une épaisseur
qui est moins chaude et qui permet
d'avoir des logements à l'intérieur plus
frais
d'architecture
et donc c'est oui c'est patients mais
c'est vrai qu'ici pardon je vais
étouffer
voilà ça y est revenu après c'est vrai
qu'ici dans cette ville nouvelle au fond
vous êtes vous-même
la question en effet de
alors vous dites il y a plus de
démolition mais la question de
l'adaptation c'est bâtiments elle est
très forte non mais s'impose
et on voit déjà que certains bâtiments
ont été transformés un des premiers
bâtiments de bureau qui ont été
construits à Saint-Quentin a été
complètement transformé et il a une
nouvelle image aujourd'hui les bâtiments
autour de la gare notamment vont subir
des transformations alors certains sont
démolis d'autres sont complètement
transformés et on les reconnaît à peine
mais c'est une deuxième vie voilà
trouver une deuxième vie à ces bâtiments
c'est important
parce que c'est vrai que oui dans les
années enfin 60-70 on n'avait pas du
tout les mêmes préoccupations
ce sont les architectes la
caton-et-vasale qui ont gagné le prix je
pritzler l'année dernière
et qui construisent de manière très très
intelligente des deuxième peau au
bâtiment c'est un peu leur manière de
faire et qui permettent de conserver les
bâtiments des années 60 70 en leur
fabriquant une deuxième enveloppe
que vous disiez tout à l'heure plus de
plus de démolition on essaie de
réhabiliter de trouver les moyens de
réhabiliter ces constructions donc ça ça
sera le 15 septembre un peu partout dans
les Yvelines si on est sur ces
territoires on va vous voir avec que ça
a eu on va visiter la au fond un peu la
vue d'une nouvelle quoi c'est ça et
maintenant c'est une opération nationale
essayer de France peuvent s'en saisir et
il faut s'inscrire sur le site les
enfants du patrimoine d'accord c'est
pour les enseignants voilà les
enseignants peuvent s'inscrire
les enfants du patrimoine
donc ça c'est le 15 septembre alors il y
a un concours alors qui est intéressant
absolument tous les particuliers
qui s'appelle le concours de la maison
économe alors c'est un concours qui
existe déjà depuis une dizaine d'années
organisé par les deux agences de
l'énergie des Yvelines l'agence de
l'énergie de 50 ans en Yvelines qui est
installé tout près d'ici et
énergie solidaire qui est l'agence qui
s'occupe du nord du département avec le
ciao dans le jury donc les architectes
du CE participent à choisir la meilleure
maison de l'année alors il y a deux
mentions une mention équilibre ce qui
veut dire que on choisit une maison qui
a été bonne à la fois dans l'écologie
dans l'énergie dans l'architecture et
une mention remarquable pour une maison
qui a vraiment peut-être un look
particulier
de gagner un vélo électrique quand on
gagne ce prix et le CUE est dans le jury
du Prix donc voilà c'est c'est plutôt
des maisons récentes
sont concernées également
voilà et donc sur notre site internet le
site du CIAU 78 on peut trouver les
informations mais aussi sur les sites
des deux agences avec Saint-Quentin et
énergie solidaire et ça alors c'est
jusqu'au 16 juillet
si vous avez une maison vous pensez
qu'elle est économe et si vous avez
besoin d'un vélo électrique
si vous voulez gagner essayer de gagner
un vélo électrique ça vaut le coup quoi
c'était intéressant en plus de montrer
sa maison
des architectes qui sont dans le jeu
il y a à la fois des personnes qui
regardent l'énergie la manière les
matériaux et l'architecture
des arts
vous faites avec le château de
Versailles alors oui on se dit voilà
c'est du sport on arrive bientôt aux
Jeux Olympiques tout ça est lié voilà le
château de Versailles a voulu s'inscrire
dans dans cette idée d'organiser des
Jeux Olympiques aussi culturels et on
proposait au ciao d'être un des arts
donc il y a les arts visuels les arts
plastique et nous nous avons été
interrogés sur l'architecture et le
design d'accord donc pendant une semaine
au mois de mai nous avons reçu
500 personnes pendant une semaine
complète du mardi au dimanche autour
d'atelier que nous avons proposé sur le
pavillon de porcelaine par exemple parce
que nous étions au Grand Prix non et le
Grand Prix non avant sa forme actuelle
était un petit pavillon porcelaine donc
on a proposé un atelier sur ce sujet là
on a proposé un atelier sur les décors
un autre sur les marbres un quatrième
sur les jardins et les parfums avec des
cyanotypes préparées par les personnes
et puis un dernier sur les origamis pour
montrer les flottilles qui flottaient
sur le grand
pour faire des petits bateaux des petits
bateaux qui présentaient la flottille
qui existait au 18e siècle sur le
les étangs et le grand canal voilà
et ça c'est passé
mais il y a une il y a trois jours
encore fin juin et des journées au mois
de juillet donc sur le site du château
de Versailles on peut s'inscrire encore
donc on peut y aller à la fois en classe
donc les écoles peuvent s'inscrire mais
aussi les personnes
les personnes individuelles et familles
je reviens à ce qu'on disait au début
quoi c'est pour vous c'est une période
passionnante au fond
aussi pour nous en tant qu'architecte et
pour l'équipe du c.io d'avoir des
questions toujours différentes et sur ce
sujet de la de la transition et de
l'énergie comment l'architecture peut
s'adapter et comment l'espace public
aussi peut s'adapter puisque la chaleur
aussi existe dans l'espace public donc
comment aider les élus les habitants à
transformer dans leur jardin ou leur
espèce publique
pour que le réchauffement soit moins
fort donc toujours végétalisé essayez
d'enlever la sfalt partout on a une
tradition de de peut-être de voilà le
BTP en France ou les ponts et chaussées
ont proposé plutôt de d'artificialiser
les sols et aujourd'hui on en est plutôt
à natureer les sols à renaturer
plutôt de la nature oui donc c'est vrai
que c'est une période tout à fait tout à
fait passionnante et pour vous et pour
nous et elle est on disait voilà les
particuliers sont assez à l'écoute assez
demandeur il y a une voix les
jugement mais les élus aussi sont je
pense que c'est une des de leurs
préoccupations c'est compliqué hein
c'est très compliqué leur finance se
réduit donc ils ont un enjeu majeur
parce que de toute manière les
successives les oblige à faire mais ils
sont très demandeurs également et très
inventifs donc cet après-midi je vais à
Versailles Grand Parc animés avec
françois de Mazières un atelier sur ce
sujet puisqu'ils ont des Plans Climat
énergétaires territoriaux à construire
pour les pour faire en sorte que leurs
habitants soient mieux conseillés mais
aussi pour que eux rénovent leur
bâtiment public d'autant que on est dans
un territoire où parler tout à l'heure
du château de Rouville ou du château de
Versailles un territoire extrêmement
patrimonial
mais est-ce que finalement c'est
peut-être que c'est c'est
bâtiments anciens sont peut-être pas si
mal
effectivement les bâtiments anciens ont
souvent des épaisseurs de livres très
très larges voilà
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque de Louis XIV il
veut pas que climatisation
mais dans les maisons rurales par
exemple
les fenêtres étaient petites et les
épaisseurs de murs étaient petits
étaient large au contraire les matériaux
étaient souvent de la terre ou de la
meulière qui sont intrinsèquement
intéressants du point de vue de la pour
garder la fraîcheur l'été notamment donc
il faut plus tôt rénover les toitures ah
oui quand on rénove sa toiture quand on
isole sa toiture souvent on réduit sa
consommation d'énergie et on a moins
besoin de rafraîchir l'été
merci infiniment alors voilà on va on
trouve tous ces événements et sur le
site de CAE et on va le mettre sur les
mettre sur notre site aussi
bravo
pour tout ce que vous faites et puis
pour réfléchir voilà ce que ce que va
devenir le monde dans lequel nous allons
vivre mais nous réfléchissons pas tout
seul heureusement avec toutes ces
personnes je pense qu'on peut y aller et
faire de belles choses merci
[Musique]